okay we're speaking to folks um who
presumably are fans of the show
although sometimes they're not via the
david pakman show discord which you can
find
at davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to
uh let's go to irina irina from
uh from where from where
irina you're on the air sirik
from zurich wow that's a that's a
perfect city
europe yes from europe oh europe i
thought you said zurich switzerland
switzerland yes that's right yeah oh you
are in switzerland okay
yes well i didn't think i would have the
chance to talk to you
and i'm very grateful for your um
comments that you give and
and also it's interesting to see the
press briefings
um of the new president biden
and it's it's so it's good to compare it
i'm not
yeah that's i'm very it's it's very
informative and helpful and
often when i get angry you you make a
good comment
so i'm very glad to hear that
it's it's very interesting irena would
you say that
the opinion of the united states now
that trump has been removed and joe
biden has been put in
is it improving is our reputation within
switzerland improving at all
uh i think so i think so okay
i mean um of course i
i follow it uh you know i also listen to
uh mr chomsky no i'm chomsky and
yeah i hope that the biden
administration will be more
more strong maybe you know maybe at this
point they will
really just continue to
do the things which are necessary for a
humane
democratic society yes
in zurich um that this riot on the 6th
of january had a
repercussion that the crazy brother of
vegetarian chain
tibbetts they have a brother and he
i don't know whom he wrote but it's
written in our
newspaper he wrote to a military officer
to um to imprison
our federacy federal government
yes because of the
of the corona measure
measures they took and um
yes i mean he was totally inspired that
was only a few days after the riots
in the um in washington dc
and i was glad that
i mean here it counts as crazy but
you know i think i hope that
trump will be um impeached
and convicted of course yes he has been
impeached but now the trial yeah
percussions
yeah he will i mean that he will have a
uh really that that it's clear he did
the crime
right right because this will have
repercussions to europe
i am sure of it we are so america
centered that um you know europe is
still very american-centered
still arena thank you so much for the
call i'm gonna let you go because i have
a lot of people waiting always great to
hear from our friends in
switzerland switzerland one of my
favorite favorite countries
let's speak next to
uh radical capitalist jack
radical capitalist jack you are
on the area just had a one question is
uh
do you think anything further is going
to happen to uh marjorie
taylor green um i think she stands a
chance getting removed from uh her
position or now
no i don't think so if you look in
history at when
members of congress have actually been
expelled it's been
five uh two of them were actually
convicted of crimes
and that's why they got expelled the
other three were supporting
the confederacy in the civil war so it's
it's i i don't see it as likely all
right thank you
my pleasure okay there we go there is uh
there is jack
uh radical capitalist jack